3d gesture control technology has been a
big emerging trend here at CES 2012
we've already seen it in Microsoft's
Kinect and Samsung announced it would
also have gesture control in its
upcoming smart TV platform we decided to
take a look at a few smaller companies
and see where gesture control technology
is headed in the future behind me is
Samsung's transparent LCD it's one an
innovation and design engineering award
here at CES this year it's 46 inches
1366x768 resolution and it's about nine
millimeters thick and weighs 10 pounds
it's really cool it's a TFT LCD display
so you can touch it and it reacts to
your touch you control it via hdmi and
USB and it could totally end up in our
homes one day it could be your desktop
display you could even have it on a
window kind of like it is here with the
blinds you could even use it in the
boardroom kind of displaying information
from your work about your employees
about an upcoming meeting it's really
cool I love checking out this future
tech here at CES this is Leonardo a new
kind of 3d modeling software it's really
cool because it lowers the learning
curve 3d modeling is normally really
hard you've got to know a lot of math a
lot of programming with this it's all
about your artistic abilities you're
basically carving your 3d model in the
air using a kind of stylist called a
bird you also wear 3d glasses and their
sensors that send on your computer
screen that perform I tracking right now
it's being used by some universities and
medical facilities a basic purchase is a
thousand dollars and that includes the
bird the sensors the eyeglasses and the
software we're here at soft kinetic
checking out there near mode interaction
prototype basically it's going to bring
connect like gesture controls to your
laptop in the coming year will see it as
a clip-on for your laptop kind of like a
webcam the year after that though it'll
be built into laptops South kinetics
depth sense technology can detect
objects as close as 15
centimeters connect on the other hand 50
centimeters as the closest you can get
South kinetic software can also detect
more details like your individual
fingers so this could be used to replace
mouse controls and keyboard controls 3d
modeling and controlling our desktop and
notebook computers are just a few ways
we'll see 3d gesture technology being
used in the future we'll have to see CES
2013 how far this technology really goes